>> Male presenter: Best thing about Matt's
story is that it stays with you long after
you read it.
So it's one of those stories that, when the
next time the world is beating you down and
you're facing a challenge that you don't think
you can overcome, Matt's story will remind
you to get from the long journey from 'I can't
and I won't' to 'I will'.
Matt could be speaking to a group of hundreds
of people right now at the New York City Marathon
Expo at the Javits Center but he's here talking
to us today.
So let's give him a warm Google welcome.
Ladies and gentlemen, fellow Googlers, Matt
Long.
We're going to start with a quick video.
[music]
>> [singing]
>> Female news announcer: A city firefighter
riding to a bike work was hit by a bus this
morning.
39-year-old Matthew Long is in critical condition.
>>Mayor Bloomberg on video: His condition
is grave, and I ask you all to pray for him.
>> Doctor on video: He was basically impaled
by the bicycle seat.
He lost his blood volume -- people would estimate
four to five times over.
So, if we took all the blood out of his body,
gave it back four or five times, that's about
how much blood he lost in about ten, eleven
hours.
>> Mike Long on video: They said that it was
serious and that he had about one percent
chance to survive.
[end of video]
>> Presenter: Matt, thanks so much for coming.
It's great to have you here at authors at
Google.
For those of you who don't know, this is the
book The Long Run by Matt long with Charles
Butler a great writer from Runner's World.
So, for those of you who don't know your story
-- and I'm guessing most of the folks in this
room do, but maybe some folks will be seeing
this on YouTube who don't know this story
-- tell us about those terrible events that
happened all the way back on December 22nd,
2005.
>> Matt: Well, if you lived in New York in
2005, it was very cold winter.
And it happened to be a time during Christmas
when the city is at its peak for tourists
and just people shopping and the like.
But the transit authority went on strike.
>> Presenter: Oh, yeah.
I haven't forgotten that.
>> Matt: It was day three of the transit strike
and ironically my last day at my detail at
the fire academy.
So I had no way to get to work.
Actually, I could have gotten to work but
I couldn't get home if the strike didn't end.
So I rode my bike.
I got four blocks from my New York City apartment.
And a private bus that was hired to bring
their workers down below the restrictions
that the mayor put in place an illegal right
turn and ran me over.
>> Presenter: Just ran you over.
>> Matt: Ran me over.
Whenever I tell people I was run over by a
bus.
They're like, "Nah, c'mon.
Yeah, you look fine.
You are hit by the bus?
What happened, it knocked you down?
" I said, "Look believe it or not, for some
reason, I was not I didn't bounce off the
bus.
I was taken under the chassis of the bus
>> Presenter: You were basically crushed.
>>Matt: Crushed.
>> Presenter: I'm going to read off some of
the injuries.
This is from your book.
>> Presenter [reading]: compound fracture
of the femur and tibia.
Broken left foot.
Broken right shoulder.
The seat post of your bike it basically ripped
right from between your legs and your body.
>> Matt: Ouch.
Do you have to there?
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Even now, it must feel painful.
You've probably heard this story a million
times and it's still painful to say.
Oh, and by the way, you're bleeding to death.
>> Matt: Yes.
>> Presenter: And you now have less than 5
percent chance of living, perhaps even just
a 1 percent chance of living.
>> Presenter : It's really hard to fathom.
It almost doesn't sound real.
You needed 68 units of blood.
>> Matt: In the first ten hours.
>> Presenter: In the first ten hours alone
and the doctor said you were losing four,
five times your normal amount of blood.
>> Matt: One of the interesting things about
that day.
I think the mind is just incredibly powerful
thing and as soon as I got hit, I don't remember.
>>Presenter: You don't remember any of this,
do you?
>>Matt: I don't remember any of it because
I think the mind said, "listen if this guy
is going to survive, he doesn't need to have
that memory because he won't survive mentally."
So I've gotten told all these stories from
different people that were involved.
And one of the stories while I was under the
bus and the police from the ESU and the rescue
fire department guys were trying to lift the
bus and get me out.
They were having such a hard time doing it
because of my blood.
They were slipping and sliding on my blood
on the street.
One of the police officers totally broke protocol
and reached into my thigh and held my femoral
artery shut because it was severed.
And he needed to slow the bleeding down and
he did it with his bare hand which was total
no no in emergency service protocol; you know
we just don't do that anymore.
You have to be gloved.
You have to be protected.
You have to take care of yourself.
I'm grateful for that guy.
>>Presenter: And that saved your life.
>>Matt: That was the first step of saving
my life, for sure.
>> Presenter: Prior to the accident, you're
pretty darn good athlete.
You ran the New York City marathon.
Qualified for the Boston marathon, something
probably less than 1 percent of all athletes
get to do who take to marathon running.
Had some iron man under your belt.
So another thing that probably saved your
life according to doctors was the fact that
you were in such amazing shape at this time.
>>Matt: I remember my mom telling me the doctors
came out.
I can't believe.
That would be the worst part about being trauma
doctors going out to the waiting room telling
the family the person you're working on may
not make it through the night.
My mom was told that, the doctors basically
"he has a 1 percent chance to make it through
the night."
And my mom said, "Doc, you don't understand.
He's got to make it through the night.
He just qualified for Boston marathon.
He's running in April."
[laughter] So I think it's that Irish Catholic
stubbornness.
"No, no, no, he's not going anywhere."
>> Presenter: Of course.
And it was that stubbornness, --whether you
were conscious or not--, that probably saved
you.
>> Matt: Yeah.
And the doctor said, flat out, once he realized--.
He was a runner, too, my trauma surgeon.
Once he realized that I was that fit to do
a 3:13.
Then maybe there's a better chance that he
could make this.
>> Presenter: So this was a real tough time
for your family, those close to you and whatnot.
They kept by your bedside and saw you through
it.
>>Matt: For five months.
My family -- there was constantly a family
member at the hospital.
There was fire department family at the hospital.
And then, my triathlon running group, Asphalt
Green, they were there as well.
So it was kind of funny.
My family.
We talk about it now because it's funny now.
I'm here.
I don't look too bad without my shirt on.
[laughter] I have an ego they said when they
introduced me.
>> Presenter: That was Murphy.
>> Matt: My family jokes about it now because
the fire department cooked for me for five
months and my family.
I wasn't eating food for two.
But they were cooked for every night.
So Monday through Friday, you got chicken
parmesan, spaghetti, pasta.
Everything was large quantities.
Comfort food.
Saturday and Sunday, the triathlon crew came
in and you got vegetables.
[laughter] Healthy foods.
My parents are "this is great; we'll get ready
for Monday night."
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Nice. [chuckles] What do you
remember when you woke up?
What's the first thing that happened when
you woke up from this?
It was almost like being in a coma.
>> Matt: Yeah, I basically was out for like
five or six weeks.
Much like sitting on this stage.
I woke up and there was this big white light
in my eye.
And I asked, "where am I?"
This is not a PG show?
>>Presenter: Uh, no.
It's ok.
>>Matt: I tell you what my first word was.
My first word was, "Fuck.
I'm hungry."
[laughter]
>>Presenter: Firemen don't like eating, do
they?
[laughter]
>> Matt: And my dad looked at the nurse and
apologized.
[laughter]And then said I think he might make
it.
So that was his story for me to tell me that
was my first words.
My first memory was my brother, Jim, coming
and telling me that I was, you know, run over
by a bus and I kind of looked at him like
-- but I really couldn't move that well.
And I was in the bed and I had a stabilizer,
an external fixator coming out of my abdomen
and my legs.
I was just looking around grabbing this metal.
He's like, "you know sit tight.
You're going to be okay.
They're taking care of you."
I was, "like nah nah when can I go home?"
And that was my first question.
"When can I go home?"
They were just like, "You're going to be here
quite a while."
>> Presenter: Before the accident, if I can
say, you were kind of like the single guy
Manhattan, bit of a lady's man.
In shape.
[laughter] You own a couple bars.
You're living the life.
And now you wake up from this accident; you
literally couldn't move.
So that was I'm sure really really tough for
your psyche not just the physical pain.
>>Matt: Yeah, I mean, my life was turned upside
down.
And I was, I guess, the consummate bachelor,
I guess you want to call it.
I had three bars.
I was firefighter.
>> Presenter: You were living the life.
>> Matt: Living the life.
[laughter] If I was an overnight guest, I
didn't have to get up early and leave.
I didn't work a regular schedule.
[laughter]
>>Presenter: Nothin' wrong with that.
>>Matt: Make the bed.
Make breakfast.
Go ahead, honey.
[laughter] That happened once in awhile.
>> Presenter: Never.
Your parents going to be watching this?
This is definitely not a PG talk
>> Matt: They don't know how to get on YouTube
[laughter]
>> Matt: My father said, "what's Google by
the way?"
>>Presenter: He did?
>>Matt: He said "what's Google?"
I said, "Nah, Talk to you later"
[laughter]
>> Presenter: You're going to tell them about
this later?
Can we set him up with like a Google Plus
account or something?
It'd be great.
>> Matt: AARP?
Do you have that with Google?
All right.
We'll work that out.
>>Presenter: So fast forward a bit.
Rehab, recovery.
How many surgeries did you need just to live
just to sort of get yourself out of the hospital?
>> Matt: In 14 months I went through 42 different
surgeries.
It was kind of -- you know, I remember like
later on after leaving the hospital I think
the count was up to like 33.
And I knew I had three more surgeries to come.
And every time I went into the operating room.
You sign.
You go in and they prep you for surgery and
you sign your releases.
And I remember one not so funny moment.
I was just so frustrated.
Get deeper and deeper into depression.
When they came to sign the release I wrote
DNR on it.
And the nurse was like, "No, no that's not
what we want."
And my mother's like "What are you doing?"
Had to get another release and sign it.
There was always two releases.
This is the release for what we hope will
happen when we open up.
And this is the worst case scenario, what
we might do and then there will be another
surgery.
And every time I went in, I'd wake up.
I'd feel another hose or connection to my
body.
. This didn't happen.
So I got to come back.
So 42 surgeries in about 14 months.
>> Presenter: Wow.
Wow.
So just to be the able to walk and be released
from the hospital was a very lengthy process.
>> Matt: Yeah, when I left the hospital, I
was walking maybe 50 feet.
And not unassisted.
I was on those Canadian crutches you saw in
the video.
Pretty much in and out of a wheelchair.
My younger brother, who I call Number 9.
>> Presenter: Meaning you have a family of
nine kids.
>> Matt: Nine kids; 7 boys and 2 girls.
It's funny when you look at a family picture.
It starts off pretty tall and number 9 is
is a little short.
It was he was the fastest long but he didn't
get a lot of food, on Friday nights there.
[laughter] The little duckling gets kicked
out.
>> Presenter: So you're out of the hospital.
You're trying to re-acclimate to life.
And it was obviously a tough time as you just
said.
In fact, I remember there was a -- we're both
graduates of Iona college.
And every year Iona sponsors a wonderful race
called the Dolan Run in honor of a friend
of yours, Kenny Dolan.
I remember seeing you in previous years.
Actually, let me clarify I remember seeing
the back of your NYPD or FDNY jersey as you
passed me on your way to the finish line.
>> Matt: Thanks for clarifying.
[Laughter]
>> Presenter: Of course, of course.
2006, you're there but you're in a wheelchair.
You didn't even look like yourself.
I remember that.
There was a great band there and they played--.
There was this--.
"Long May You Run", I think, and they played
that in honor of you.
>>Matt: Neil Young.
"Long May You Run".
It's Hell or High Water.
They've been friends of mine for years.
And they donate their time for that race every
year and that race is probably 18 years now.
>> Presenter: In the book, you describe saying,
maybe to your brother or a buddy of yours,
you said you didn't have the heart to be there.
It just wasn't you.
In previous years you would have been up there
maybe accepting a prize for winning your age
group or something along those lines and then
maybe having a beer and a burger after listening
to the band.
You just wanted to get out of there.
>>Matt: I did.
I remember my brother called me up saying,
"Hey, today's the Dolan Run."
And I was only out of the hospital--, it's
the first Sunday in June at Prospect Park.
I'm out of the hospital two weeks.
I got out May twenty-second.
Two or Three weeks, I said, "yeah, you know,
let's go.
Let's see what happens."
Because the Dolan family was great to me.
And I just thought it would be good to show
up.
When they wheeled me into the -- after party
for the race, listen to them play the song.
I was just like I got to get out of here.
I just wanted to be involved.
>> Presenter: And that was kind of a theme
in your life.
It was hard to be out socially be out with
your usual group of friends.
>> Matt: You know, probably -- obviously,
you're in the hospital five months, you're
not a happy person and no one was really faulting
me for not being myself.
But it wasn't until I got home and there was
not that bell at the side of the bed when
I need something from a nurse.
Now, it's about "this is your life."
>>Presenter: So you were depressed.
Majorly depressed.
>> Matt: And getting worse.
>> Presenter: And who brought you out of it.
>> Matt: Mom.
I went in for a doctor's appointment and you
know at this point in my life I was making
deals with God.
I was constantly just fix this.
Just take care of this and I'll deal with
the limp and I'll deal with a cane.
I'll get through.
Just give me this one thing.
And when I went to this doctor's appointment
the doctor said to me, "Mr. Long I don't think
we're going to be able to help you.
You just had too much muscle damage and nerve
damage."
So we left.
And I just talked to my mom and dad.
Listen I'm so glad that you guys prayed for
me and your prayers were answered and I lived.
But I wish you would have prayed for me to
die.
>>Presenter: That must be so hard for a mom
for a son to say something like that.
>> Matt: You never want to say that to your
mom.
I was crying.
She was crying.
And I expected her to reach across the table
and hug me, you know "This is when you hug
me; I need you right now".
I'm hitting the button for the nurse; hey,
where's the nurse And she just put her hands
down on the table and said, "enough is enough."
She said, "you know, you have to think about
all the things you've done before this accident
and you need to pick up the pieces and live
your life the best you can."
>> Presenter: It's tough love at a time when
you needed it the most.
>> Matt: I was just like, you know, I was
so taken aback.
She just basically said if you're going to
do this; if you're gonna be a miserable SOB
for the rest of your life, do it by yourself.
Leave us out.
>>Presenter: Smart woman
>>Matt: That jump start the whole train..
>> Presenter: So at this point you say to
yourself all right I want to be an athlete
again.
And you went through a lengthy additional
rehab recovery process, went to Arizona, worked
with some great trainers out there.
Tell us what it was like just to be able to
run one mile.
This is a guy who could run a marathon in
well under 3 hours and 15 minutes before now
you're struggle to run just one mile.
>>Matt: What really happened is I didn't say
I wanted to be an athlete again.
I started to say I will be an athlete again.
That's when the training kicked in and I went
to Arizona.
I was e-mailing.
I wanted to get away from New York, that was
the first thing.
Mentally, I need to be out of here.
I talked to my friend, Frank Carino.
I talked to my friend, Noel Flynn.
I was like, "I hope you guys don't mind.
I hope this isn't like I'm bailing out on
my support system, but I need a change in
scenery."
I need to forget about everything.
Even the homeless guy outside Starbucks.
When I'd walk with my crutches, he'd say "hey
you're the bus guy".
And I was like everyone knows me.
I need to get out of New York.
>> Presenter: And the sunshine helps.
>> Matt: And the sunshine helps, yeah.
So I e-mailed a couple of warm weather facilities.
A couple people e-mailed me back saying amazing
story; you've been through so much.
We'd help you but you should have realistic
expectations.
And I was like, "how can this person tell
me to have a realistic expectation without
even seeing me or knowing me."
So I was just delete, delete.
And then I found via Google.
>> Presenter: Of course.
[audience chuckles]
>>Matt: You know?
How else would you search the web.
I found the place called the Functional Performance
Center in Tempe.
Very small.
Smaller than this room and a young guy who
went to Iowa.
Either Iowa or Iowa State, I'm not sure.
He e-mailed me back.
He was a runner.
He said, "First of all, I would never tell
anyone they couldn't run again."
>>Presenter: And that's what you needed to
hear, I'm sure.
>>Matt: I moved down there three days later.
>>Presenter: Wow
>>Matt: Frank Carino had just had his second
child.
I haven't flown since my accident.
I don't know what to expect.
I need help.
He came with me.
Got an apartment.
And I lived there three months.
The first day I said how is all this going
to help me run.
He said well, let's strengthen your body and
one day we're just gonna do it.
After three months, I went in and they were
like "let's go; today's the day".
And I was scared.
>>Presenter: Probably scared you were going
to topple right over.
>> Matt: Topple right over.
It was like oh, you didn't prep me for this.
Last night I could have been thinking about
it.
If you're doing an endurance race, the night
before you visualize your race.
What can go wrong?
How am I gonna fix it.
I didn't have any visualization for a mile.
And we did it.
We did it in 18 minutes, 24 seconds I think.
And we stopped at the half mile turn around
point.
I was like okay.
Then we tried to work on my gait a little
more.
When I finished, we went into therapy.
>>Presenter: So, in a lot of ways, the same
way you had to learn to be a good endurance
athlete the first time around, you had to
learn it a second time, really.
>> Matt: Yeah, I dig the mechanics of running
-- things you take for granted.
When was the last time you got out of your
chair and thought about walking?
We just do it.
And I had to do that.
I had to think about even taking a step.
And it's very, very odd..
>> Presenter: So now you've completed one
step in your recovery.
You've actually successfully gone for a run,
maybe a few runs.
Now, you tell your doctors I want to run in
the New York City marathon.
What do they say?
>> Matt: One doctor said I'm crazy but then
he said all you guys are crazy.
[laughter] Why would you want to run a marathon?
They didn't tell me not to try, but they said
I would tear myself up pretty good.
And I said, "I needed it."
You know?
I needed it for my head.
I needed it for the mental recovery.
You know, I just needed to see that finish
line to know that this was -- a part of my
life that will never, ever be behind me because
of how I am now but the come back is over.
I'm here.
Like that kind of thing.
>> Presenter: You wanted your life back.
>> Matt: I wanted my life back.
>> Presenter: And running, one of the biggest
-- along with your family-- probably one of
the the biggest your past and your present
life.
>> Matt: Absolutely.
>> Presenter: Tell us about marathon day when
you finally came back.
>>Matt: My -- so I had the fire department
drive me to the start.
I got a 3 hour head start with the Achilles
Track Club.
I got a great story about the start of the
marathon.
They picked us up in a van, myself, Noel,
and Frank 'cause I had 2 buddies.
I figured 40,000 runners are going to be coming
from behind me.
Maybe I just need two people to make them
go wider.
>>Presenter: Why not?
I mean Lance Armstrong had it.
>>Matt: He had about 8.
[whispers] Sissy.
[regular voice] I'm sorry [laughter] That's
later in the book.
Later in the book we get to Lance
>>Presenter: Actually, let's pause one second.
You got to meet Lance Armstrong after you
-- little bit after you -- about a year after
you had gotten hurt.
Can you share that story real quick?
I love that story.
>>Matt: Obviously the marathon a big part
of my day.
This weekend, the energy level is so great.
So the guys in the fire department thought
it would be great to take me to the 2006 start.
So they pick me up.
I was still in a wheelchair part-time.
But I went with my crutches and Lance was
running.
It was his premier marathon.
And they got me to the start and they kept
tapping one of Lance's entourage on the shoulder
saying "hey, you got a minute?
Can Lance say hello.
This guy got hurt on his bike; he got hit
by a bus".
Lance had his sweat suit on.
Ipod in his ear.
He's just getting tuned into the race.
Meanwhile all the pros are kind of on the
line in their shorts and tank tops freezing,
but Lance had his swim jacket on.
Two minutes, Lance, and another piece came
off and he's getting ready.
So they begged him.
My boss is a big Italian guy.
He says, "Aw, screw this".
He pushes on of Lance's guys and says "hey
Lance.
Get over here.
Talk to this guy."
[laughter] So he comes over to me.
And I said, "Lance c'mon.
They gave you 50 percent chance.
They gave me 1.
You got a minute?"
[laughter] At that moment he was taking his
thing off, "what'd you say"?
And I got the picture.
>>Presenter: So that really got his attention.
>>Matt: That got his attention.
In his books and when people talk about him,
people say you can't break his face.
I broke him.
[laughter] I knew I got him right there..
>>Presenter: You can take some credit for
him breaking three hours.
Barely
>> Matt: Barely.
I think he did 2:58.
>>Presenter: Right around there.
>>Matt: He doesn't have to get his own water.
[laughter] They were handing him water.
>>Presenter: That's true.
He got the star treatment.
>>Matt: C'mon.
Like Alberto Salazar.
>>Can't get a better pacer than that.
>>Matt: If he'd got me my water when I was
running, I would have went well under 3:13.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: Two years later you're doing
this.
You're running the race.
You got your buddies along with you to ensure
your safety.
You get to mile 3 and your family is there.
What was that like.
>> Matt: Let me go back.
>>Presenter: Oh sorry.
>>Matt: [laughter] Is this my interview or
yours?
>>Presenter: I'm pretty sure the book is by
Matt Long.
>>Matt: I don't know this was going to be
a comedy set but this is pretty good.
Let me go back to mile 1 because this is a
great story in the book.
My buddy, Frank Carino, is next to me.
The cannon goes off; they wish us well.
There's about 35 challenged athletes.
Single leg, double leg, single arm, maybe
a blind runner and boom, cannon goes and off
we go.
The first mile is uphill.
And I'm looking in front.
I'm like about 29 athletes just crested the
and I'm back with Frank and Noel.
Am I in last place?
Already?
Like we're not even at mile one.
[laughter]
>>Presenter: Wow
>>Matt: And I can't really turn; my balance
is really off.
So I'm like, Frank, serious, just tell me,
am I in last place?
."Matt, don't worry about it.
Keep going.
We've got a long day ahead of us."
"Frank just turn around and tell me if I'm
in last place."
Now we're bickering.
He's like my man wife.
[laughter] We're fighting there right on mile
one.
He turns around and he goes, "Matt you are
not in last place."
"Great.
Let's go."
So we got our pace we're going.
All of a sudden I hear this clicking noise.
It's getting louder and louder.
What's that?
Frank's like, "Oh no".
[laughter] He knew what he saw when he turned
around and this Japanese runner, double leg
amputee just swinging himself on the crutches
that I was using just six months ago to walk,
passes me.
Frank goes, "now you're in last place."
[laughter] I'm like, "it's going to be a long
day."
That was mile 1.
Mile 3 is when I had my first stop plan.
I said to my family -- I said this when I
did a 3:13.
You guys can really come out and be on the
marathon course.
It would be great to see you but please know
I'm trying to qualify for the Boston and if
I run by you at 7 minutes pace, don't be mad
that I didn't stop to say hello and you've
been freezing waiting for me to come by.
I'm just not doing it.
In this race, I knew I'd be out there for
about 8 hours.
You're going to be at multiple spots.
Mile 3 is the only time I'm stopping.
They were outside the church where I grew
up in Brooklyn; the whole family.
So I stopped.
Got rid of whatever I did after warming up
for three miles.
Got rid of a shirt or something went on my
way and it was great to see them out there.
>> Presenter: But you still had 23 miles ahead
of you.
>> Matt: 23.2.
>> Presenter: 23.2 to be exact.
Obviously, this took a great deal of mental
will.
Physical strength just to get through it.
Just to -- not knowing if you might not finish.
Not knowing if you might fall over but you
did it And it took you what, about 7 hours?
>>Matt: 7:21.
7 hours 21 minutes.
You're allowed to clap.
[laughter and applause]
>>Presenter: Probably a wonderful day for
you.
Wonderful step in your recovery, but this
wasn't enough.
You weren't done.
You still had another act.
What did you tackle next as an endurance athlete?
>> Matt: I wanted to become the Ironman again.
man again.
I wanted to hear Mike Reilly say "you're the
I wanted to hear mike say you're the an again.
I wanted to hear mike say you're the again.
I wanted to hear mike say you're the Ironman"
again.
I didn't know how I was going to do it because
running hurt.
Not that it doesn't hurt anyone that does
it.
It just hurt me a hell of a lot more.
And basically during my training for the marathon
I only got up to 14 miles.
Frank and Noel had run that.
Frank and Noel are both sub three hour marathoners.
So to ask a guy who can run a 3 hour marathon
to run for 7.5 or 8 hours, it takes a lot
out of a person.
I said to them, "you know, if I run three
miles in Central Park takes me 45 minutes
and then I can't do anything for two more
days.
So how am I going to train for 140.6 mile
day as an Ironman.
So I just switched it and did it all on the
bike.
250-300 miles on the bike and maybe a mile
on Saturday.
And then you know, but I knew.
>> Presenter: Was it hard to ride a bike after
what you'd been through?
>> Matt: Yeah.
You know, I had two choices.
I had a bike custom made for me because I
had a leg length difference.
Some weaknesses so balance was an issue.
So I went to this guy, Paul Levine at Signature
Cycles and he built me a bike.
When he called me and told me it was ready.
I was sitting in my apartment.
You know, now I have a bike.
It's always this big thought.
I'm going to run a marathon do this.
I have a bike now I just have to go get it.
So I got in my car and I said if I go over
to the west side to pick up the bike and put
it in my car, I'm going to look at it in my
apartment for a couple days.
Instead I got dressed to cycle and hailed
a cab.
So I was forced to get on the bike.
And I went like corner to corner looking.
>> Presenter: Real gingerly.
>> Matt: It was mentally tough.
The toughest part about it was when a bus
went by and I'd be standing on the corner
looking at that 8-inch space between the chassis
and the street and go how the hell did I get
under there?
Then I look at the scar under my stomach and
I know how I got under there, they stuffed
me.
>> Presenter: So just to ride through New
York City streets.
>> Matt: I road through the streets.
Got into Central Park.
Took one lap and went home.
I knew I had a lot of work ahead of me because
I was exhausted.
>> Presenter: So for those of you who aren't
familiar with the Ironman distance, it's 2.4
mile swim.
112 mile bike ride followed by a full marathon.
So this was what?
2009?
Back in Lake Placid.
>> Matt: 2009.
Lake Placid.
And you have 17 hours to finish.
17 hours and 1 second, they pat you on the
back and say "come back next year".
No medal; no t-shirt.
>> Presenter: One second off, you're not an
Ironman.
>> Matt: That's why it's called Ironman.
Firm believer that it's ok to have a cut off.
I didn't think I would be anywhere near 17
hours.
I thought I would be 15, 16 hours.
I was 12 minutes slower on my swim; about
a half hour slower on my bike.
I knew I had a long day ahead of me in the
marathon because I only did a 7:21 in New
York.
There's all sorts of people going around "well,
if you could do a 3 hour marathon then you
should be able to do a 3:30, 3:35, 3:40 in
the Ironman."
There's a lot of different equations you can
mentally put together for yourself.
I wound up running 7 hours and 30 minutes
and finished in 16:58:06.
>> Presenter: Just made it.
>> [Applause].
>> Matt: Best part about it, they were giving
me my medal.
They wanted to interview me and they started
saying "Wait, wait, there's one more out there."
And at 17 hours on the button, this guy comes
in.
He'll be forever known as Last Man Paul.
>>Presenter: Last Man Paul.
I love it.
>>Matt: And he comes in give and they go,
"Give him his medal; give him his medal.
This is unbelievable."
Because I was the guy they were following
with the camera all day.
And they were like, at mile 23 the guy from
Ironman came out and said, "Matt, I'm JD from
Ironman.
I'm here to make sure you get in".
He had GPS.
He could tell me how fast I had to run at
this moment.
So I was the everyday hero.
So I said to JD, I said, "JD have you ever
had a hero go to zero in less than 17 hours?
[laughter] He said, "nope".
I don't want to be the first.
Let's get moving."
>>Presenter: He's your motivation.
>>Matt: So Last Man Paul finishes.
I put the medal over his neck and I say, "What
happened to you?
He said, "what?"
I said, "what happened to you?"
He said, "what are you talking about?"
[laughter] He's just been out there 17 hours
and he's confused.
"I just got run over by a bus.
What happened to you?"
He's like nothing.
[laughter] I was like "yes."
I was afraid maybe he'd say double decker
bus.
The cameras would go right off of him.
I would be here, Paul would be
>> Presenter: Go to YouTube and just type
in Matt Long Lake Placid.
A really cool clip comes up.
It's grainy; it's a little wobbly.
The noise is deafening from the crowd.
You'll have to turn your speakers way down.
It's a really inspiring clip.
You can see Matt finish.
>> Matt: That's my brother, Frank, screaming,
"Love you!"
[laughter]
>> Presenter: And then you do see last man
Paul just before the clip ends.
It's pretty cool..
>> Presenter: Speaking of YouTube, how have
you been able to, you know, utilize technology,
social media, to sort of, you know, really
get the word out about you and about your
cause -- the I Will foundation?
>>Matt: You know, I'll tell you a story about
my -- one of my, I guess, mentors who helped
me recover.
When I was home in my apartment and wasn't
able to get around by myself.
My brother Eddy Number 9.
I was trying to give him his space.
Get out.
I had a big box of cards and letters that
I got written to me.
Give me that box.
Put it by the couch.
I'm going to start reading some of these.
You go out for the day.
And when I opened up one of the cards a newspaper
article slid out and kind of went away from
me so I couldn't reach it.
And I went through and through and through.
Later when my brother comes home, I said,
"Hey give me that article" but now I have
no idea who sent it to me.
I read this article about a gentleman cyclist
in Massachusetts six years prior to my accident.
But a mirror image.
By reading his, you can just put my name where
his name was same broken bones.
He's from Massachusetts.
I'm from New York so I trumped him a little
bit.
[laughter] He had 17 surgeries, I had 42.
He spent 3 months in the hospital, I spent
5.
He got 20 units of blood, I got 69.
I got you a little bit.
[laughter] But through the Internet, I found
this guy.
You know, this is a 6-year-old article.
And I just went crazy on Google.
Putting his name in taking that article apart
his doctors, where he worked I called the
bike shop he worked at 15 years ago.
Yeah, we know him.
He's still in the area.
I go I'm going to send you a link to who I
am because I don't want you to think I'm crazy.
And I would never give out someone's phone
number to a stranger.
I'm going to send you a link.
Can you read it and realize the urgency why
I need to speak to this man.
We have never met in person still to this
day.
>>Presenter: Complete strangers.
>>Matt: We e-mail; we talked on the phone.
And I said to him.
His name is Fabio Selvig.
You helped me and I'll do my best to help
others.
I need you.
Like you've been there.
No one else could come into my house and say
"hey, I was hit by a bus last week and I'm
doing jumpin' jacks now".
He was back to cycling.
Back to living his life.
He was married with kids.
Happy.
He basically said to me all the best things
in his life happened after his accident.
And that was like my light.
All right.
This is great.
So he did.
He helped me and then once it was over, I
said I need to be more accessible.
I can't take two or three days on the Internet
to find Fabio or the next person doesn't need
to do that for me.
So I started the I Will Foundation.
And I put it on the Internet.
And I just figured that it would be an inspiring
story.
Hey, I'm having a tough time.
I got hurt and this and that.
I found this guy.
He did it I could do it.
Then it just turned into bigger.
>> Presenter: So you started the Foundation.
Tell us about what sort of folks benefit from
the I Will Foundation?
>> Matt: Our mission is to help people who
have suffered life altering illnesses or traumatic
injury like myself.
We want to help them get back into life.
You don't have to be an Ironman.
You don't have to be a marathon runner.
But just live your life -- not feel like you're
secluded like I felt those months when I was
depressed.
The first girl we helped -- well, the first
guy I ran the Ironman for was John Gleeson;
he lived on Long Island.
Cyclist; hit by a car.
After 120 mile bike ride, finished with two
of his buddies and all he had to do is cross
the street and a car plowed him when he was
crossing the street.
And he's got a phenomenal attitude John.
Had some complications.
We helped him with equipment.
We helped him with training.
we sent him to California for an aggressive
stroke rehabilitation plan.
Because he had a stroke during one of his
surgeries.
He ran a 5k without telling anyone last week.
He called me up and told me "I just ran my
first 5k".
He didn't care about the time.
He and his wife side by side.
We helped him.
He helped the girl who had a stroke at 33
years old become an Ironman She was a national
ranked swimmer and they told her she couldn't
swim anymore because she couldn't turn her
neck.
Within a year of having the stroke, she did
an Ironman in 11 hours 30 minutes.
And now we're helping a guy, a phenomenal
guy, you'll see all over Youtube as well.
After I did the Ironman, the bike company,
they were so impressed they made another bike
for me.
And I wish I would have had it at the Ironman
because all modern technology, electronic
gear shift.
This is great.
So I shipped the bike to Florida for a training
trip with some of my friends.
The bike shop down there says you got to meet
this guy, Hector.
They knew my story.
And I met a guy who about 15 years ago was
electrocuted.
Blew both of his arms off; one at the elbow,
one at the shoulder.
And he modified his own mountain bike and
would be able to brake with his knee.
But he couldn't change gears -- no hands.
So I brought him up to New York with the foundation.
And we had Paul from Signature build him a
bike.
And he puts the stump of his elbow which is
just a big muscle mass now.
He has so much control of the muscle he can
hit the buttons to change gears and he's cruising
by people on the bike now at the races.
He's going to do the first Ironman in New
York next year.
That's part of what we're doing.
>> Presenter: That's fantastic.
You're really starting to see the fruits of
your labor with the I Will Foundation in action.
>> Matt: You know, what I'm really -- I know
really why this accident happened to me after
years.
Or even months where I talked to a family
priest.
And you know I know why now.
You know I know why I got in that shape.
I know why I survived.
And I found I got a purpose to just inspire.
>> Presenter: You're inspiring helping others.
It's great.
When word got out to the office that you were
going to be coming the Daily Show clip from
earlier this summer was circulating.
You and John Stewart having it out for a few
minutes.
You mentioned that you were competing in the
World Police and Fire Games.
What's next for you as an athlete.
What are your plans?
>> Matt: Well, I I'm going to try out for
the Paralympic cycling team.
The Paralympics are in August in London in
2012.
I went out to Augusta, Georgia, for the Paranationals
in June.
I'm a class 3 Paralympic National Champion.
>> Presenter: Congratulations.
>> Matt: Before you clap, there is an asterisk.
[laughter] I was the only class 3 that showed
up at the race.
And when I realized that I told the guy.
They had the podium set up.
As much as I really want to be on that top
box, I'm like I'm the only one that showed
up.
The guy's like it's not our fault if they
didn't show up; you're a national champion.
All right I'll get up on the box.
[laughter]
>> Presenter: And you're a competitor once
again.
>> Presenter: So I want to open this up to
questions from the folks here from the Google
New York office.
Some of you might be running your first marathon
on Sunday perhaps and you've got a great resource
here.
If you just want to step up to one of the
microphones, we'll open up questions to Matt.
>> Male #1: Thanks so much Matt for coming.
You're an incredible story.
I ran my first marathon in New York last year
and I remember reading your book right before
it.
Huge inspiration to me.
A lot of us here at Google and around in New
York obviously still commute on bikes to work.
And you know, it's still a pretty big problem
as far as safety and regulations.
What do you think is the best solution as
far as awareness or as far as things the city
can do both cyclists and drivers can do.
>> Matt: You know, I don't want to get in
trouble with the Mayor, my friend Mr. Mike.
But personally I think the bike lanes they're
putting in are just wrong.
You know, I don't think they're thinking it
through for the commuter -- the cyclist, you
know?
First of all as a cyclist you're told when
you go to the park if it's raining, the first
thing you do is stay off the white painted
line because it's slippery.
And they paint the four foot bike lane all
green.
Just doesn't make sense to me.
But that's my opinion.
You know, New York is a busy place.
And the cyclists all have to really -- let's
face it, if you have an accident, we're the
ones who are going to get hurt.
The car may get dented but nothing's going
to happen to the car or the bus.
That bus was still working the next day and
I was in the hospital for five months.
A cyclist -- people who want to commute on
a bike, you got to really just make sure you're
visible and make sure you obey the traffic
laws.
I cheated a light here and there but you have
to try your best because you want to get to
where you're going.
If you're late, so be it.
Better be late than not show up at all.
>> Male #2: So thanks very much for coming
today.
Yeah, I was thinking about something you said
in the beginning which is the mind is extremely
powerful.
It's almost as much as the body, I think if
I'm quoting you right.
Just after the accident and I was just trying
to think how I would react.
Of course I have no perspective.
There's certainly a lot of people you could
have blamed for this happening.
Transit union striking.
Bus driver.
Whoever it was.
So there's got to be a bitter resentment in
the beginning especially causing you to have
that depression that you described.
How do you get over that?
How do you stop blaming everyone else and
get over that to the place that you are today,
which is amazing?.
>> Matt: Don't get me wrong.
I did blame them.
[laughter] And you know, I wouldn't have been
on my bike that day if the strike didn't happen.
So that's the way I look at it.
And if I ever saw Roger Toussaint who called
the strike, which, I would tell him that.
But you can't hang on to that.
If you want to move forward in life, you can't
hang on to the anger.
You can't constantly tell or use an excuse
that someone else is holding you back from
getting where you want to be.
And when I was depressed and when I was not
moving forward in life.
There's key words I like to use when I talk
about it.
I wasn't dreaming anymore.
I wasn't setting goals anymore and I was just
thinking about all the things that were taken
from me because of that day.
Once I let go of that, those were the anchors
that are holding me back.
Once I let go of that, the mind took over
with a positive attitude and I started to
change and I started to see my strength.
I mean, in that picture, I was 128 pounds.
You know, it was -- once I got rid of those
anchors, I started to see the strength come
back.
I started to see, "hey I went into a surgery.
I woke up.
Hey wait a minute.
I got the one I was supposed to get?"
And I really believe the mind was now in control
of that.
And it was going to be up to me to do what
I did.
And you know, I had the will power to do it.
>>Male #2: Thanks
>>Presenter: Any other questions?
>>Female #1: Thanks For being here.
I'm really excited to read your book next
week.
I am running on Sunday and I'm emotional,
nervous wreck.
So.
>> Matt: Don't read it yet.
Wait till Sunday night.
>> Okay.
What gets you through some of these races
and long runs?
Do you have like a mantra you repeat to yourself?
Something you visualize?
What gets you through those 7 hours or 16
hours?
>> Matt: Before my accident, I just fed off
the crowd, the energy of the crowd.
I was lucky enough to race with good people
and good friends that were faster than me.
Men and women.
So I pushed myself to, you know, get closer
to them in a race.
I remember in one half Ironman I did with
my friend, Vicky, and Frank Carino, again
you hear those names all the time in the book.
It's when I just started my run and was really
coming around.
And we start in different waves.
So you see each other at different parts of
the course but I passed Vicky for the first
time in my life on the run course and she
was like "whoa".
And I was like "where is he" because frank
was faster than both of us.
And she was like what?
We're in the middle of a half Ironman.
70.3 miles He just turned the corner up there.
He was lieutenant in the fire department at
the time.
I yelled out, "Lieutenant, I'm coming".
And you know Vicky was like "you're crazy"
and so I just took off.
That was what motivated me before was the
crowd.
Pick a person in front of you.
See that purple shirt?
I want to stay with that purple shirt.
Mile 5, I want to pass that purple shirt and
that will motivate you to keep moving.
After the accident, no matter how hard I try,
i I'm a 16, 17 minute mile.
It's really, what I say to myself is "I will".
A good friend gave me some advice about a
marathon and Ironman.
Every once in awhile ask yourself what can
I do right now to make myself have a better
day?
To make this race better?
And it could be the next water stop.
I'm going to get my cup of water and I'm going
to walk.
You're not going to win the race, you know?
So five seconds instead of taking that paper
cup and splashing the water in your face and
getting just a couple drops and now you're
soaking wet, pull over to the side drink it
like a lady, [laughter] throw it in the garbage,
and run again.
Whatever it is at that moment to help yourself
have a better day do it and you'll just enjoy
it.
>> Female #1: Thanks so much.
>> Matt: Welcome.
>> Male #3: Thanks very much for being here.
This is very inspirational.
I'm curious -- this may be a bit technical
but you talk about having a change in mechanics.
The pictures suggest that there's a lot of
metal going on in your body.
[chuckles] How does it change the technique
and mechanics.
What did you have to work on?
How is running that mile different today than
it was five years ago?
>> Matt: So I said I have a leg length discrepancy.
My legs are the same length, okay?
But my pelvis was shattered so badly that
the doctor the best they could do is kind
of like the right side is close to an inch
higher.
And there's like a 9-inch titanium screw that
holds that there.
I remember going he apologized he said if
it was a painting I wouldn't sign it.
It's not my best pelvis repair.
I said, "oh, okay."
He goes," but, I had the screw ready to drill
it in and you were dying.
So do it now fix it."
So I said okay I'm not upset, Doc, I'm here.
So I have special shoes made.
So I, you know, it took me awhile to find
a running shoe company that would make it
for me but this company Zoot Sports, they're
a triathlon, multisport company.
I sent them what I was doing.
Basically I was taking a running shoe to a
cobbler and he was putting a piece of rubber
on it that would make one shoe weigh about
2 pounds and the other shoe about 8 ounces.
So I would drag it.
With that lightweight foam whatever they built
an inch lift on a running shoe for me.
So that helps that helps me stay level.
But as far as my muscle mechanics go, my right
side a lot of my stabilizer muscles and the
big muscle groups for running -- hamstring
-- they didn't come back to full strength.
So what I've learned is that, you know, the
body wants to be healthy.
You know, people talk about, "oh, I can never
do this.
I have a bad back."
Well, you probably have a bad back because
you're not active.
You don't have, technically, a bad back.
Your back hurts when you get off the couch
because you're not treating your body right
and your body wants to be healthy.
So when I was going through therapy in New
York with the performance guys, when I was
planning for the marathon they would tell
me, "Listen don't worry about your weakness
in this hamstring because the muscles around
it are going to pitch in because the body
wants to do right.
And so it did.
I just had to talk to different muscles to
keep moving.
That's basically how I had to keep those mechanics
going.
>> Presenter: Well, Matt, I know this is really.
Oh sorry.
>> Matt: Let's go.
I have all day.
You don't want to go back to work do you?
It's Friday.
Google stops at 12 o'clock?
[laughter]
>> Male #4: Super inspirational story.
I heard you speak at Ironman Lake Placid this
year when I was doing it.
I had crashed my bike seven weeks beforehand.
So I just want to kind of get your feeling.
I'm still really tentative on the bike from
the crash from the Half Ironman before Lake
Placid.
How did you get your mind to go screaming
down key when you're worried about everything
else and having been hit by the bus.
How did you work your mind around that?
>> Matt: Yeah, which is great.
I that was the best part of the race 6 miles
downhill.
I got my bike up to 50 miles an hour.
I can't do it in aero position like some people
do it.
I hold on for dear life.
I think it's like anything else.
You have to kind of think back to being a
kid.
And kids try everything, try anything, fall
down, get back up, do it again because they're
not afraid.
So you have to try to lock that out.
Bring back that child inside you and say,
"granted you have to keep in mind the risk
and the reward.
Go with precaution.
I know a guy who's a phenomenal cyclist but
after he's married and has kids, he's on the
brakes that whole time and he used to just
fly down.
You have to keep it realistic for yourself.
Find that inner kid in you.
If this happened when I was 12, once the cast
is off, I'm back out there.
So same kind of thing we have to do.
As we get older, recovery time is what we
don't have.
That's why I don't try snow board.
I remember trying to snow board and I fell
like six times.
The next day I was like I can't move.
I just learned how to ski.
I'm going to keep skiing.
I'm okay with that.
As you get older, you can't recover as fast.
Find that inner child in you get rid of that
fear.
You'll be all right.
>> Male #4: Thanks so much.
>> Female #2: I'm wondering how you view yourself
now versus how you thoughtful yourself before
the accident.
You know, we all have a pretty good sense
of ourselves.
And then, when something like that happens,
your spirit's broken and you know, that's
why you went through that phase.
And some of the things that define us before
something like that happens and they're taken
away from us causes us to think differently
of ourselves afterwards.
How do you view yourself now?
>>Matt: As Mr. Murphy said, I have a little
bit of an ego.
[laughter] I was always a confident person
before the accident.
That 2-year journey where it was kind of sucked
out of me, I guess, without sounding too cocky,
you know, I realize that I'm tough son of
a bitch.
Basically that's it.
I got that from my parents.
I was put through an awful lot and I wouldn't
want my worst enemy to go through what I went
through.
But I know for a fact now that you don't do
things by yourself.
You know, if it wasn't for my mom and dad,
my brothers and sisters my fire department
friends and family, Vicky, Frank, and Noel,
the triathlete group that I trained with,
if it wasn't for that support group, I'm a
huge country fan.
Kenny Chesney has a song, I didn't get here
alone.
I didn't get to this point alone.
I know that now more than ever that I relied
on those people and those friendships to get
me where I am.
And to make this recovery and this comeback
possible.
But I'm still tough son of a bitch.
>>Presenter: There's your mantra.
[chuckles] Well, Matt, your story has been
tremendously inspirational to me personally
and to a lot of the folks here at the Google
New York City office.
I know this was a busy week for you with the
New York City marathon being Sunday.
So for you to take some time out of your schedule,
we really appreciate it.
Thanks so much for coming back.
>> Matt: Thank you.
Thank you.
[Applause]